shot clock is off crowd comes to its
feet the atmosphere
in this place is electric this building
is shaking in here
[Music]
man when the season halted
oh my goodness bro it hurt
being in okc we got to witness firsthand
the postponing of the season
[Music]
and the fans are just left clueless and
then that day you kind of felt the
levity of the situation
that made a lot of sense to stop it when
we didn't know much about
what we were facing with kovitt life
paused
things changed the world stopped when
the season holds it it was just
like okay what's next i was disappointed
obviously because as a super fan i look
forward to going into td garden
i really do miss sports in general just
watching the competition and
whether i'm at the arena or at home just
miss me
it's like you're on a high and all of a
sudden the pandemic hits
man you wanna you're on a low again all
reports say the nba
is inching closer to returning i need
you
it's been sad it's been so sad and
lonely without sports
before the pandemic hit oh my goodness
baby we was on our way
just feeling good like you know we were
set to really catch a groove
i just hope they're able to recapture
some of that going into the bubble in
[Music]
orlando
my name is daryl bailey man but you all
know me baby aka clifford girl in the
building baby
my name is nav bhatia my name is garrett
haviland
but you all know me as thunder this is
nasa basale aka aztec
it's your boy big snoop deal double g
king of the west coast representing the
lakers
i've been supporting the thunder since
the very first season since my college
days
coming from the beautiful islands of
trinidad and tobago
when nba arrived in toronto i
fell in love and i have never missed a
game for last 25 years
i decided you know what i got a big gut
beautiful mural painting so why not go
with it the very first painting was a
jack-o'-lantern
darren williams went to shoot a
technical free throw ripped my shirt off
and unveiled the first thunder belly
yard
since the pandemic man what i've missed
about basketball is the camaraderie with
the fans
we are a one big family when i go to the
game it's my whole
extended family from a fans perspective
it's disappointing
not to attend the games but my players
know that we are going to be there
in spirits it's going to be different we
know that they're supporting us no
matter what
to know that i'm not going to be there
to cheer my guys on is going to be
just a complete mind explosion i'm
thinking about going to orlando man just
stand by the door man hopefully
somebody let me i don't think people
understand how much energy all the fans
bring to the game
the way the crowd roars the adrenaline
that you give it's just a certain
feeling that can't be matched
goal of the super fan is to make sure
everyone who attends a game
enjoys the whole ambience having their
raw emotions god can feed off of that
energy and
it kind of brings everything together
not having fans in the building
is definitely going to impact the
players when they go to shoot free
throws i mean who's going to be there to
distract them
the players are going to miss feeding
off the energy of the crowd just because
you're not there
don't mean you're forgotten we know that
you're there or we're gonna play hard
for you guys
y'all just don't know man i can't be
there to cheer my guys
man this hurts when i get to go back to
a full arena
getting to see all the familiar faces my
usher gaylord like i know i'm gonna have
to give that dude a big old bear hug
when i go back to the arena i'm going to
be back with my family
the high fives handshakes and hugs they
all take photos with me
you know they like it when i do that i
can't wait to get them back in our
building
what i'm looking forward to the most man
seeing my 2020
allied clippers champions baby getting
them rings i like their chances we have
a great team
we are the defending champions the first
time the world didn't
believed us but we're going to prove
them wrong again
who can stop us baby i'm telling you man
it's our time come on
thunder i need you to rise up and
dominate
we know you guys are still there we
appreciate you we need you
you take care of the business in orlando
i'll take care of the business in
toronto
stay safe stay healthy championship but
nothing we got to come back home with
that thing
when i say l.a you say clippers am i
okc k c celtics
number one gold raptors go